hallo leute hier wieder einmal waren und
heute mache ich rahmen aber keine ganz
normalen rahmen
init eine klitzekleine rahmen und zwar
habe ich vor
ich glaube mittlerweile einem oder zwei
jahren
tiny food gemacht und viele von euch
wollten das wiedersehen deswegen gibt's
heute eines meiner lieblings gerichte
tatsächlich rahmen
ich muss dazu vorweg sagen dass sie
jetzt nicht so super klein werden so wie
man es in manchen youtube videos sieht
wo die leute auch wirklich so eine
klitzekleine küche haben
ich mache einfach mit clubmanager sind
also das wird das wird die ganze portion
und sonst ist so eine rahmen schüssel ja
so groß also sehr groß ist eine kleine
portion wenn man sich wie ich mit dem
thema rahmen beschäftigt hat weiß man
dass es viele verschiedene arten von
rahmen gibt also es gibt nicht das eine
rezept heute möchte ich ein
vegetarisches rezept machen weil es
einerseits mit so rückenmarks knochen
viel zu lange dauert und andererseits
auch viel komplizierter ist sondern
bekommt zum beispiel mit shiitake pilze
auch so ein gutes aroma dass man das
fleisch gar nicht vermissen wird das
rezept was ich dafür benutzen werde ist
von meiner freundin
die hat uns mal so ein schönes paket
zusammengestellt und ein rezept dazu
gepackt ich weiß nicht woher das ist
aber es war sehr lecker und deswegen
halte ich mich daran
und das lässt unsere teenie teilen die
rahmen brauchen wir ja natürlich denn
eine gute rahmen suppe braucht für mich
immer ein und wollte mein instagram
stores erfolgt wisst ihr dass ich
wachteleier benutze dann brauchen wir
noch knoblauch und karotten da habe ich
jetzt die super klein gekauft es wird
eine teilgruppe frühlingszwiebel ersetze
ich durchschnitt laut ansonsten kommen
noch pilze chili nie so pasta sauce
shiitake sesam seetang und minimal und
natürlich weiteres gemüse was man darin
haben will wie zb pak choi und dann
beginnen wir mit der zubereitung
ja ich habe mich umgezogen mir war zu
warm ja ich weiß dass es auch pullover
aber das ist ein lockerer
dozic erhältlich ausmachen wir weg als
allererstes werden wir diese starke
pilze 30 minuten in kaltem wasser
einweichen
[Musik]
ein kleines trockenen tag resümierte ich
die gar gebeten
heute sagt man wie findet ihr diese
zweite kamera ich hab mir heute versucht
die produktion ein bisher hoch zu
schrauben und ich glaube es gefällt mir
ganz gut als lebensbereichen wir schon
mal unsere eier form zwar müssen wir sie
zwei minuten kochen
kleine wie große einheiten klein heißes
wasser auf flächen geben deckel zu unser
wasser kocht nun und wir können unsere
wachteleier hinzufügen und ab geht die
lutzi einmal läuft werden dass koch geht
es weiter mit unserem gemüse und zwar
nämlich märchen die kirchen ich habe
aber nie kitschig noch teilweise kleine
geräte benutzt aber es macht halt so
viel schwerer
deswegen es reicht dass es am ende klein
aussieht so klein
[Musik]
ja
diese eier kommt in ein kaltes bad
jetzt kümmern wir uns ums gemüse und
schneide ist klein ich fange ich schon
an wie meine oma anna stift also ich
würde sagen das sind dünne stiften man
braucht meine vergleichs schale die dann
da so drin sind schon ganz schön großen
wissen ja noch dünner sein
jetzt habe ich aber wirklich hier werden
muss man gar nicht kaufen weil sie halt
in dem heißen wasser glaube ich schon
ein bisschen also die sind so denn die
würden in dem hatten die werde dem
heißen wasser safe durchkommen ist es
nie selig ich dreh durch endeffekt sind
ganz wichtig auch mal kleine schalen
damit ich diese sachen aufbewahren kann
wird mir leute haben jetzt eine kleine
schale und da kommt meine kleinen
gestifteten münchen mit knoblauch
hinweisen
ich brauche doch noch grünes zwiebel
natürlich nicht für die deckung aber für
die brühe frühlingszwiebel check der
antrieb und timo bildern wie man so
knicken douglas auseinander kriegt da
was meine hände wenn mir zustimmen also
den besseren trick ab zum knoblauch
schälen schreibt ihn gerne in die
kommentare und nachdem wir den knoblauch
drei stunden lang haben schneiden wir
ihnen kleine schein und kommen jetzt
nicht mit warum benutzen keine presse
warum heißt nämlich die fresse nehmen
sie einen topf der groß genug ist um
dinge zu erledigen die sie vorhaben
hatten sie noch den kopf fällt drücken
sie auf stadt und mich mein schumi öl
was leider immer noch dann ist es tut
mir leid habe einen fehler gemacht und
toni öl gekauft
also bitte wartet jetzt quasi das liegt
daran kommen und in der zeit stehen wir
nicht drum herum sondern kümmern uns um
unser pak choi diese teile brauche ich
guck mal
aktuell gibt es quasi auch in mini weil
in den körper drin kleine kita käufen da
wir auch sehr darüber freuen
so jetzt warten wir unseren knoblauch
aus während meinen freunden snacks sucht
drei esslöffel nie so passt sowieso
paste ist quasi einfach früher wurden
passte ein esslöffel stieler
[Musik]
mit einer wieder mit kleinen games with
my heart ich habe auf jeden fall kleinen
schneebesen ulrich heiß und stinkig und
südseite nicht genug zeit um sich
aufzuweichen und kommen in ein sieb dass
vögel wie aus und das fühlt sich
überhaupt wirklich an ein essen ist
nicht eklig und shiitake pilze sind auch
deine freunde die bereiche gelegt werden
okay und kohle uns ist super geil wie zu
waschen sie sich umgehend an zwischen
den fingern wow
shiitake pilze soll ich nehme jetzt mal
die hälfte und schneite sie und taxi mit
in die brühe patrioten machen wir auch
noch rein champignons wirklich das
kleinste aroma- und wusstet ihr dass man
sie sogar helfen kann ja dazu müsst ihr
jetzt geht es weiter mit der tunesischen
müssen sie machen die ganzen toppings
kümmern dafür nehmen wir unseren
schnittlauch und tun sollte aufs politik
üben werden toll toll super toll so
jetzt haben wir natürlich die typischen
ringe schnettler und sowohl wisst ihr
was auch ein toller tipp ist nicht zu
beeilen wenn man schnitte und gehe das
kommt die sonne
rheinische fällt unsere nächste weko ist
zucchini doping und dafür benutze ich
einfach nur meine parmesan reiben stadt
die große reibe wie große zucchini nun
klein so unsere suppe köchelt und das
darf sie jetzt mindestens zehn minuten
machen und so vor sich hin köcheln als
nächstes brauchen wir unser seetang
glatt und zwar gibt es dann immer so
große scheiben an der seite und das ist
halt nicht schwer nachzumachen wir
müssen sie aber nur klein machen
[Musik]
das gibt so viel einfacher ich bin so
dumm so das kann dann halt hier so in
der suppe sitzen ist ja nur die blätter
jc 001 marty um so unsere eier kamen
leichten grünstich aber das ist gar
nicht schlimm
jawohl ich habe auch vorher große rein
und hoffe dass sie vielleicht ein
bisschen bräunlich werden wollen so
realistisch wie im glück geld mit den
remix so und ab hier wird sie zu groß so
das reicht eigentlich auch schon unsere
miniatur wunderland hier jetzt kommt das
wofür euch am meisten angst hatte die
nudel rahmen nudeln selbermachen in
super dünn ich hab ja schon mal
einrahmen suppe zusammen mit anderen
gemacht die von naruto und dort haben
wir rahmen nudeln selber gemacht das ist
aber schon sehr lange her das sieht doch
ganz gut aus als müll wasser salz sind
machen wir jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen gehe sogar ich natron nur in
tablettenform haben nämlich jetzt eine
tablette natron in dieses ding hier
fühle mich als ob ich eine apotheke wert
also eigentlich müsste man das metronetz
backen damit es bei kalisch david und
gelblich sowie man
kennt aber wen juckts ende des tages
sein zusammengemixt schön daraus machen
jetzt ganz easy und ohne stress test ist
eine coole da kommt unser wasser rein
also nudeln machen das wirklich
eigentlich keine kunst sind aber auch
alles hier augenmaß ich sag mal so wenn
man ja kein tiny kitchen dann kann man
jetzt auch ganz wie sie einfach fertige
rahmen aus dem supermarkt nehmen da sie
jetzt aber so klein werden müssen machen
wir selbst sowie super teig zum
aufrollen benutzen wir speisestärke und
schuss größte konkret was sie finden ist
der ist jetzt wissen wir den tag
schneiden wenn ja wie gut ihr das sehen
könnt ihr euch jetzt die erste nudeln
[Musik]
ja sie schneidet die nudeln und wir
sehen uns ein gläschen sie koche nicht
gerade sexy es songs lang geschnitten
wir stellen das mache jetzt und die
zweite so wasser kocht hartmanns toll
ein paket in kochendes wasser rein
springen da ein bisschen rum dann heute
auch ein eisbad denn wenn rahmen nudeln
kochen muss man sie sofort keine sekunde
länger kochen bald auch die halt super
dünn sind heißt das wasser vorbereitet
also eigentlich macht man so ein nest
mit dem
kontakt man das nest ins bettchen hier
rein ist und tropfende wasser ist unklar
und ab ins eisbad nicht immer ganz kurz
dem pakt rheinland jetzt geht's los geht
doch gerade die nudeln liegen im
bettchen okay wir kümmern uns jetzt um
die traktion erstmal die blätter schauen
wir mal wie das ei geworden ist dadurch
gekocht man dabei habe ich das sogar so
gemacht
aber was wir haben ist dieses schöne
braune faktor schneide ich auch noch mal
eine hälfte durch so zucchini märchen
meines ist eingelegter mais aber so und
dann machen wir jetzt die brühe sieht
aus wie eine rahmen suppe ja wie soll es
denn sonst aussehen ist chili fürs
geschmack und lauchzwiebeln
[Musik]
du bist meine leute samt ney machen und
gleichzeitig probieren
wow dass sich so ein ei
[Musik]
es war eine gute idee das ei in die
sojasauce zu packen da hab ich hat das
noch mal so ein richtig seit sieben
leckeren mantel und bei den rahmen geht
aber um die nudeln eine ordentliche
portion von süß bis zum neckar com mit
dem problem ein du weißt doch am ende
sieht man sich eben wieder nicht weil du
zu groß für die kamera ist ein letztes
kleines restaurant hallo und danke für
die verkostung hier
[Musik]
lecker sind groß
vor dem premiere nur so kleine
einleitend wir noch eine weitere idee
habt was ich dann im teil die kochen
soll vielleicht auch mal wieder was in
der normalen größe preis aber nicht mal
wieder ein bisschen mehr kochen normalen
größen überlegung ab sofort an zu teilen
das dachte leute typs ich hoffe euch
jetzt gefallen wir sehen uns immer
wieder und jedoch ein ei zum schluss
lecker lecker bis dann